when i was a younger man i was a bit of
a meathead
and i hung out with other meatheads and
um there was
a game most meatheads played every now
and then called hang brains
a couple people know that game uh hang
brains is when you walk into a bar with
just your nuts out
and the winner is the guy who gets
discovered
last because he gets free drinks do you
know who never noticed our nuts not one
time
women not one not one no it was always a
guy like hey bro your nuts are out
hey you know your nuts are out your nuts
are out
always never not one we were always like
what it was always a dude like your nuts
are out ha ha
conversely if a woman walked into this
dark room right now
just shirt unbuttoned down to here with
an eighth
an eighth of an areola showing not even
forget the areola
just a mole next to the areola so she
walks in with a moleola right
if she walks in here with a moleola
there would be a murmur around the guys
until he get to this guy he'd be
googling porn help molly oil i'm jerking
off to that tonight for sure